sacudió al fútbol sudamericano al
publicar un audio acompañado de una
serie de documentos en los que aseguran
fue una investigación interna de la
federación ecuatoriana de fútbol en 2018
y en la que Byron castillos declara
haber nacido en una fecha distinta a la
de su documentación ecuatoriana y con un
hombre diferente además presentan
documentación que acreditaría Castillo
como si hubiera nacido en Colombia El
Diario apunta así a un supuesto
encubrimiento por parte de la federación
para que Castillo continuara jugando con
los colores de la Tricolor esto llega
después de que en junio como les hemos
contado aquí la FIFA archibara una
denuncia de chile contra Ecuador por
este caso la roja pide los dos puntos de
los dos partidos que jugaron contra
Ecuador algo que si de casi en caso de
aceptarse cambiaría por completo la
clasificación para la copa mundial de
Qatar 2022 recordemos Ecuador clasifico
de manera directa mientras que chile se
quedó por fuera de la Copa mundo Juan
que dice en todo este caso el entorno
del futbolista se pronunció su abogado
Andrés o que defiende al castillo y
aseguró que ese audio no es algo nuevo y
aquí un juez ecuatoriano dicen ya
descartó como prueba al no poder
corroborar que efectivamente se trate de
Castillo desde la federación ecuatoriana
insiste en que no hay ninguna prueba
contundente que respalde esta denuncia
de chile por su parte desde la anfp
desde el fútbol chileno su presidente
Pablo Milán dijo que esta nueva prueba
que publica el del email sería la prueba
contundente de la denuncia que ellos
llevan defendiendo desde hace meses la
pregunta del millón y que pues todo
mundo quiere saber no sé si tenemos
nosotros la respuesta puede realmente
Ecuador quedarse Juan fuera del mundial
que nosotros estuvimos consultando con
algunos abogados expertos en esta
materia Es que para la FIFA es muy
difícil intervenir en este caso por qué
Porque mientras haya una autoridad
oficial de Ecuador que certifique que va
a haber un castillo es Ecuatoriano para
la FIFA sería algo muy difícil ya que
entraría a desconocer a la autoridad
nacional En caso de que la FIFA decida
hacerlo esto abriría una ventana muy
peligrosa porque entonces estaríamos
hablando de que el máximo ente del
fútbol ya no reconociría ya no
reconocería la independencia de los
países y entraría a dudar de sus
documentos oficiales Entonces esto se
muestra como algo muy complicado por dar
un contexto de cómo se encuentra el caso
de Byron Castillo ahora mismo chile
presentó una apelación el comité de
apelación de la FIFA Está tratando este
caso el jueves Byron Castillo debería ir
a declarar ante este caso y aún todavía
después chile tendría que podría
recurrir al tribunal de arbitraje
deportivo pero es que el mundial
comienza ya en menos de dos meses como
les hemos contado por plazo se muestra
muy difícil que puede haber algún cambio
en la clasificación del mundial además
Ecuador juega el partido inaugural de
ese Mundial contra los anfitriones
contra